the crowd is absolutely electric after
1787 world math championship the
defending champion teacher is off by one
point as we head into the final question
but young up-and-coming tenure gal has
been having a monster game you couldn't
have scripted it any better than this
the teacher has selected a 10-point
question of maximum difficulty what is
the sum of the whole numbers from 1 to
100 this is an incredibly hard question
I don't know how Gauss is going to
figure it out he is going to be working
against the clock he's added the first
four numbers and gotten to ten but he
realizes this won't work he has to start
over and think more creatively he's back
to the drawing board and he writes out
the problem but I don't know how he's
going to figure it out
he's now writing the expression in
Reverse and it looks like he's going
backwards because I can't see how this
could possibly help him what's this he's
out adding up the two expressions and oh
my gosh
every single column sums up to 101 I
have never seen a pattern like this
before
Gauss has figured out something that is
going to shock the world
two times the sum is equal to 101 times
100 because there are hundred terms he
now figures out the sum by splitting the
product in half and so the sum is 101
times 50 which is 5050 Gauss has figured
out the answer and he has plenty of time
to spare to check his answer
but it doesn't look like he's content he
is changing the problem and in an act of
showboating he is going to generalize
the problem for the whole numbers 1 to n
I don't know why he's doing this it
looks like he is showing off his extreme
innate math ability he has such an IQ
you just can't teach that
he's now replacing the terms for the
problem up to n every column sums up to
n plus 1 so 2 times the sum is n times n
plus 1 he will now go ahead and split
the product so that the sum is n times n
plus 1 over 2 and Gauss needs to finish
this proof he only has a few seconds he
has forgotten to write QED that is a
requirement we've all seen it before
this play is going to be under review
but the RAF's hub rule this is an
incomplete proof gauss did not complete
with the symbol this is a controversial
ending the fans are booing and going
crazy but it looks like gas is now going
to get any points for this proof and so
by one point the teacher is going to win
the game oh my gosh welcome to the math
take on today's show we're going to
discuss the controversial ending to last
night's game and ask how does the loss
affect the legacy of Gauss first let's
hear from analytics man frankly I'm
disgusted by what happened last night we
all saw the Gauss completed the proof
the RAF's robbed him they need to change
that rule you don't need to put QED at
the end we all know that the proof ended
Gauss is an exceptional person and he's
already an all-time great and future
hall-of-famer Gauss is so far beyond the
normal that in time he's going to help
us define what the normal distribution
actually is Thanks
now let's hear from intuition guy am I
the only person who saw what happened
last night
Gauss choked ten-year-old Gauss is such
a talented mathematician but he simply
could not handle the pressure he keeps
on comparing himself to Euler who I
called the king of mathematician EUL er
but he is not at the same level as King
oiler yet Euler made contributions of
geometry calculus trigonometry algebra
number theory his equation e ^ pi times
I plus 1 equals zero is the greatest
equation of all time and even Gauss will
admit this so at this point I'm going to
call him Prince Gauss and he has time to
prove himself oh my gosh I can't believe
that is so disrespectful of you
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my channel and make videos on math you
can get my books there's a link in the
video description catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook and Google+ you can also
catch me at fresh taller on Twitter
Instagram Tumblr and Pinterest and you
can support me on patreon
you